[Musique]
certains pensent que la télévision
publique coûte trop cher et un peu
partout à travers le monde certains
remettent en question sa pertinence
alors que de plus en plus de gens se
tournent vers internet pour s'informer
en suisse on va encore plus loin et ce
dimanche on va voter dans un référendum
pour décider
rien de moins que de la vie ou de la
mort de la télévision publique suisse
[Musique]
avons nous besoin d'un radiodiffuseur
public qui diffuse des jeux et des
émissions de cuisine dans plusieurs pays
l'avenir de la radio et de la télévision
publique est en jeu
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 20 heures
des médias jadis tout-puissant parfois
de quasi monopole des antennes qui ont
marqué l'histoire sont ébranlés par la
révolution internet
la fin annoncée des radios et
télévisions publiques
[Musique]
les yeux se tournent vers un tout petit
pays la suisse est l'avenir de sa radio
et sa télévision
ici le 4 mars le peuple va se prononcer
par référendum sur l'avenir d'un des
plus vieux service audiovisuel public
vous êtes attachés à cette télévision
sur internet c'est fini là
les suisses ont peut-être décidé de sa
fin pure et 5 sommes en train de vivre
un incroyable de notre société en fait
j'ai le marchand est le pdg de ce qu'ali
de scop audiovisuel suis ce qu'on
appelle la ssr la société nationale
suisse de radiotélévision 17 chaînes de
radio cette chaîne de télévision un
service dans les quatre langues
officielles du pays
l'allemand le français l'italien et le
romanche
si le peuple suisse vote oui à cette
initiative le 4 mars
nous devrons fermer nécessaire et c'est
très bien qu'il ait peur sonia barbosa à
28 ans est une des jeunes leaders de ce
mouvement contre le diffuseur public peu
près 10 heures par année
si je soutiens autant cette initiative
ceci parce que je me retrouve plus du
tout dans ce modèle de diffusion
[Musique]
ce sont des jeunes qui ont lancé ce
qu'on appelle ici l'initiative dans la
démocratie suisse tout citoyen peut
lancer une initiative référendaire
s'il obtient 100 mille signatures pour
l'appuyer on ne s'attendait pas ce que
ça devienne aussi gros journaliste
économique
florian schwab a été ainsi initiateurs
nous étions un groupe de jeunes qui se
demandait quels seraient les moyens pour
réduire la taille du secteur public
l'idée n'était pas d'attaquer le
diffuseur public
c'était un enjeu fiscal quelle taxe
attaquez vous avez bien entendu
leur cible n'est pas tant la radio et la
télévision publiques leurs ennemis jurés
c'est l'état ils sont une force
puissante de la politique suisse ce sont
les jeunes ultra libéraux
on va pas d'être rsv changer le système
il faut dire que cette taxe communément
appelée redevance est particulièrement
détestée par les contribuables suisses
la facture arrive chaque année autour de
noël par la poste et elle est salée
voilà c'est combien le montant 413 150 l
époque là dedans tu n es pas complète si
non quelle raison parce que c'est pas
tout une année quoi c'est pas tout une
année mais sur sur une année ses 450 et
en francs 10 c'est quand même malgré
tout un budget tous les foyers suisses
la reçoivent dès lors qu'il possède un
récepteur radio un téléviseur ou un
ordinateur
aussi bien dire tout le monde
c'est cette redevance qui va financer la
radio et la télévision publiques comme
la rts en suisse francophone et qui
subventionne aussi en partie la
programmation privé en région
autre particularité suisse l'état a
confié la perception de cet argent à une
société privée
billag d'où le slogan de la campagne
référendaire pour son abolition nobila
si nous procédions comme dans d'autres
pays
en glissant ce payement dans la
déclaration d'impôts ou dans la facture
téléphone ça passerait de manière plus
douce là il arrive brutalement et c'est
vrai que ça suscite une réaction parce
que le coût de la vie est très chère
dans ce pays et que ça vient en plus
ajoutés aux dépenses donc payer un mode
de perception qui donne au flop favorise
pas
fin 2017 l'annnonce du référendum a
immédiatement séduit beaucoup de
contribuables dès les premiers sondages
en décembre une large avance était
crédité au camp du oui 57% à la ssr ce
désamour a été difficile à encaisser
je pense que ce qu'on vit c'est en
séjour ces semaines
c'est un sacré électrochoc pour la
plupart des employés de la nécessaire
vous savez quand on est au quotidien
interpellé au quotidien on doit
expliquer pourquoi ce qu'on fait on le
fait de telle manière qu'on doit
justifier pratiquement notre salaire
auprès de nos amis de nos coûts une
famille de nos voisins de notre épicier
ça interpelle
il faut dire que le diffuseur public
suisse est un des plus chers au monde
le coup est explosif 195 $ par habitant
au canada
ces 34 dollars
l'homme d'affaires andréas clip milite
activement pour la suppression de
télévision publique
il voit dans la ssr une organisation
mammouth qui a perdu tout sens de la
mesure
lors d'une élection au conseil fédéral à
berne
la ssr a dépêché deux cent trente huit
employés pour en faire la couverture
pour un seul événement c'est démesuré
ils dépensent tout ce qu'ils ont sans
regarder la réalité du marché
la loi dit que l'on doit payer et au
bout du compte il flambe 1,6 milliard
par année nécessaire un budget global de
1,6 milliard de francs
plus de 2 milliards de dollars canadiens
le quart lui vient de la publicité tout
le reste fier des contribuables le turn
ni de sextant vous n'avez pas besoin de
6000 employés pour produire ce contenu
on peut réduire le personnel de moitié
et on aura quand même un excellent
service quoique nous fassions quel que
soit le rendez vous que nous couvrons
information magazine sports
documentaires cinéma séries nous devons
tout faire en trois langues pour une
simple et bonne raison
je n'ai pas envie - francophone qu'on ne
raconte les nouvelles en allemand alors
évidemment ça a un coût mais ce coup là
c'est pas le coût des médias c'est le
coup de la suisse
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
coûts de la ssr sont remis en question
en 2015 on avait étendu la redevance aux
pme ce qui avait créé une vive
opposition
l'industriel jean françois rime ne
digère toujours pas cette augmentation
[Musique]
larnack c'est le fait qu'on prenne 200
millions aux pme alors que nos emplois y
ont déjà et moi personnellement j'ai
déjà payé
donc je veux pas payer deux fois pour la
même chose cette mesure avait été
adoptée de justesse par référendum par
une marge de 2 me d'un pour cent
la ssr avait alors promis de diminuer
ses coûts promesses jamais tenues
mais cette remise en question s'est dit
on va la faire à la mode suisse
tranquillement en prenant notre temps
oui il faut qu'on serait fort oui
au fond la façon de consommer les médias
est en train de changer on va étudier la
question
jean-françois rime est aussi député de
l'union démocratique du centre un parti
qui comme son nom ne l'indiqué pas se
situe à la droite dure du spectre
politique
je suis parti qui a mené en 2009 une
campagne référendaire victorieuse
pourrait interdire la construction de
minarets
des délégués de l'udps et si on parlait
comme un seul homme
réunis à confignon dans le canton de
genève ils se sont largement prononcés
pour le oui à l'initiative dite no
billag le 27 janvier ses membres ont
appuyé l'abolition de la redevance c'est
le seul parti à prendre cette position
mais c'est aussi le premier parti suisse
lui décès a aussi des comptes à régler
avec la nécessaire en particulier avec
six journalistes
en suisse il ya une dernière enquête ya
pas si longtemps où on ressort que 70%
des journalistes sont des gens de gauche
et donc qui développe des idées de
gauche la suisse est un pays
conservateur
je dis ça sans jugement de valeur dès
lors que dans ce pays conservateur il ya
déjà un certain temps a été pratiqué une
forme de journalisme d'investigation
dans quête de questionnements on est
dans le push il ya un petit peu quand on
remet en question certaines certaine
manière de faire alors on est
immédiatement taxé de gauchistes pour
moi c'est pas être gauchiste c'est
simplement faire son métier de
journaliste
faut-il en finir avec la redevance pour
financer la ssr nous voterons sur cette
question le 4 mars prochain est l'objet
fait déjà beaucoup de bruit
il faut dire que la question
référendaire du 4 mars est brutale
si le oui l'importent on supprimera
complètement la redevance et toutes
autres formes de financement de
l'audiovisuel par l'etat sera interdit
pour le chef de la direction
il n'y a pas de plan b les jours qui
suivraient cette dotation
évidemment que la population
commencerait à arrêter de payer la
redevance ou en tout cas la paire est
beaucoup moins la publicité
s'écroulerait parce que nos partenaires
économiques avec lesquels nous avons des
centaines de contrats demanderait
évidemment des prépaiements donc on
serait fasse un plein de liquidités
énorme et en même temps le plan social
pour accompagner la sortie de 6000
personnes vous imaginez ce que ça
représente
c'est un plan social très lourd et donc
je ne suis absolument pas certain qu'on
arrivera à le financer
les partisans de l'abolition du service
public crie au chantage et disent que la
ssr et ses filiales régionales comme la
rts pourrait quand même survivre avec
des abonnements mais davantage de
publicité j'espère vraiment que
contrairement à ce qu'affirme notre
ministre des télécommunications ils ont
vraiment un plan b parce que je pense
que ce serait totalement irresponsable
de ne pas avoir de plan b
ça c'est de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle voire voire franchement
un gag
ceux là même qui ont fait l'initiative
il ne doit plus y avoir de financement
pour un média de service public
et derrière ils disent oui mais on
financera qu'en maintenant et vous
pouvez pas dire tout et son contraire il
faut être très clair si cette initiative
passe
il n'y a plus de service public en
suisse une seconde
ce serait une catastrophe pour ce pays
parce qu'il en a besoin de par ses
différences mais qu'on ne vienne pas me
parler de plan b
c'est une sorte de fumisterie
intellectuelle
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ravis de vous
retrouver pour cette grande soirée sur
le climat oui vous le voyez partout en
suisse que ce soit en suisse alémanique
dans les grisons en suisse italienne est
évidemment ici en suisse romande les
quatre chaînes nationales simple la
suisse est une confédération de quatre
peuples et son identité est étroitement
liée à ce pacte collectif
le mandat du diffuseur public la ssr
l'obligent à offrir un service dit
équivalent en français en allemand et en
italien
le roman je parle et parle moins d'un
pour cent de la population reçoit un
service plus modestes comme les suisses
de langue allemande compte pour plus de
60% de la population
un système de péréquation redistribue
l'argent de la redevance aux communautés
minoritaires
[Musique]
les partisans du service public voit
dans la nécessaire un ciment national
ceux qui veulent lui couper les vivres
estiment que les médias privés peuvent
très bien prendre la relève
ce n'est pas le cas de laurent wehrli
maire de la ville de montreux et
président de la campagne référendaire
pour sauver le service public en suisse
francophone qu'elle privé va accepter
les coûts liés à une production pour des
manifestations qui auront lieu dans des
petites vallées de montagne ou sur l'arc
jurassien
un milieu privé par définition ne fera
jamais est c'est parti pour beatrix avec
ce panorama absolument délirant même
ceux qui veulent lui couper les vivres
admettre que la ssr offre une qualité de
production digne des montres suisses
de vancouver à pyongyang en passant par
sotchi
ce sont ces techniciens qui fournissent
au monde entier la couverture lors des
descentes de ski
une fois merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur le plateau d'infrarouge hooker
suisse romande certains de ses magazines
d'information atteignent 40 % de tout
d'auditoire disponibles de quoi faire
rêver toutes les chaînes de télé du
monde qui a lieu en ce n'était que du
divertissement
très sincèrement je pense qu'on pourrait
réfléchir à cette question là mais le
dieu visuel qui serait radiophoniques ou
télévisées
c'est largement autre chose que juste du
divertissement
et c'est là où c'est un élément très
important cette notion d'information et
moi je vous repose à imaginer que ce
sont d'information et de formation est
un produit comme n'importe quel pâte
voiture ou pneus même de marque c'est la
suisse profonde qui à mesure que la
campagne référendaire bat son plein se
mobilisent pour la ssr
car c'est elle qui assure la couverture
des événements sportifs locaux comme le
tour cycliste de romandie la politique
locale ou la musique populaire
[Musique]
les musiciens sont inquiètes way et là
ça fait peut-être un mois qu'on sent
vraiment il ya là l'opposition il ya des
musiciens il y a des gens de la culture
qui y frémaux attention c'est dangereux
et entraînant une mobilisation
nécessaire a versé l'an dernier 33
millions de francs en droit d'auteur aux
musiciens suisses celui-ci ne reçoivent
que des miettes en comparaison de la
part des radios privées qui se cantonne
dans une diffusion plus commercial
[Musique]
le milieu cinématographique est aussi en
émoi au festival du film suisse de
soleure l'inquiétude est palpable pour
les cinéastes indépendants
ceux ci pensent que sans la nécessaire
de cinéma sus existerait à peine ça nous
atteindrons notre cher presse parce que
c'est vrai qu'on s'est construit avec
cette télévision depuis notre enfance
nous autres francophones on est une
minorité en suisse et donc on se dit
c'est pas ça dépasse largement le cadre
du cinéma et des réalisateurs
c'est quasiment une conscience citoyenne
on a besoin du service public pour
assurer notre voie dans un pays qui
donne quels mots nous sommes
minoritaires car les vrais gagnants
d'une disparition de la ssr serait
possiblement les chaînes étrangères des
pays voisins qui déjà pénètre la sus de
tous les côtés et ses trois petits
marchés sont complètement couvert
intégralement couverts par les chaînes
qui arrivent de france d'allemagne et
d'italie
ces chaînes sont puissantes elles sont
fortes elles ont des programmes de bonne
qualité et elles couvrent le territoire
aussi bien que nos chaînes à nous que
nos chaînes nationales ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait la concurrence elle est
absolument phénoménal en suisse
mais les jeunes surf sur une planète
médiatique qui les fait circuler de
l'america d'afrique en quelques clics
ils sont nombreux ceux qui veulent payer
pour ce qu'ils consomment et pas
particulièrement pour la voix de la
suisse
notre génération concerne pas les médias
de la même manière et à la base ce be
like cette redevance est très précise
était précisément lié à cette à ce mode
de diffusion
alors qu'aujourd'hui avec avec la
consommation / sur internet on a
beaucoup de choses qui sont à
disposition gratuitement moi quand je
regarde mes grands parents ils ont une
vue par rapport aux médias qui est très
religieuse presque c'est à dire la voix
du journal la voix de la rts c'est juste
or nous nous avons eu un regard beaucoup
plus critique je pense les jeunes par
rapport à ça si on laisse passer cette
notion de jeu paix que ce que je
consomme alors demain les gens qui ne
font pas l'université voudront plus que
par leurs impôts au pays on met de
l'argent pour les universités ces mêmes
étudiants et ces mêmes jeunes qui ont
lancé cette initiative
ils sont pourtant très heureux d'avoir
fait des études en ne payant que très
peu par leur propre contribution
financière ou celle de leurs parents
si on regarde ce principe il devrait
payer bien plus cher leurs études
bonsoir bienvenue à tous le 4 mars nous
allons voter sur l'initiative nos billag
qui vise vous le savez la suppression du
financement public de l'audiovisuel
plutôt pudique au début de la campagne
la ssr s'assume désormais et se défend
on n'hésite plus à traiter un nombre des
conséquences appréhender d'un oui au
référendum sans redevance tout sécher
n'existe plus
ces dernières semaines beaucoup
d'associations d'organisations ont
transmis leurs consignes de vote
la grande majorité recommande le non le
monde du sport de la culture de la
solidarité surtout pour eux la
suppression de la redevance aurait de
lourdes conséquences
le vent semble tourner les sondages de
milieu de campagne donne les
abolitionnistes perdant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'initiative par 60% des bases et je
veux voir 7 1% de long dans tes
conneries
[Musique]
c'est un vent d'espoir pour ces
manifestants défenseur de la nécessaire
rassemblées à berne la capitale
s'il ya plus de service public
francophone n'y a plus du tout service
parce que le marché est trop petit pour
alimenter une vraie télévision et qui va
prendre la place
alors ce qu'il va prendre la place ce
sont effectivement des chaînes
françaises qui draineront toute la
publicité mais qui feront quelques
croupion peut-être des missions pour la
suisse mais j'aime ça ne raterait sera
jamais assez pour qu'ils fassent des
vraies émissions des enquêtes et tout
comme fait le service public et suisse
mme des prestations et des rendez vous
que les gens aiment et tout n'est pas
joué
ce sont d'ailleurs essentiellement des
employés de la ssr qui ont répondu à
l'appel
l'éthique de populaire n'est pas un camp
transition ne se soit rien n'est gagné
nous devons convaincre encore encore
plus les la population à aller voter
continuons le combat dussault 4 mars
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on gagne cette votation c'est aussi
une justification de ce service public
ça nous rendra plus forts aussi
et nos opposants devront aussi
l'admettre et ça on aura moins de
contrats rendre voilà on est légitime et
quelque part on sera le premier le
premier service public en europe
avoir un public qui nous aura soutenu
par un vote c'est quand même
extraordinaire aussi reste le secret des
urnes
combien de suisse pourrait décider d'en
finir avec une facture en faisant une
simple petite croix cela aussi aurait
des conséquences
extraordinaire on poursuit la discussion
avec luc chartrand lutte même si la
suisse décidait de maintenir leur
diffuseur public ça règlerait pas tout
non bien sûr que non c'est un débat qui
a déjà des conséquences le gouvernement
sus par exemple a déjà annoncé un
plafonnement des revenus de laisser
faire et pour les citoyens
dès l'an prochain cette fameuse
redevance qui est actuellement de 1
franc 24 par jour voient symboliquement
est ramenée à 1 franc par jour donc
régime minceur en vue pour les ssl
diffuseur public tu ce nom en attendant
on va surveiller les résultats dimanche
merci le quai au nom de toute l'équipe
de cette émission produite par la
télévision publique
on vous remercie d'avoir été là et on se
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]